c'est la période tant attendu chaque
année les moissons le moment de vérité
sur la qualité de la récolte avec 40
hectares de blé sur une exploitation de
145 hectares implantée à vic
l'agriculteur laurent tissier se
satisfait du rendement 2021 c'est une
année où on s'est fait très très peur à
cause du gel au printemps parce qu'on
est descendu avec des gelées à - 8 - 9
qui est au final la sur l'exploitation
pour ce qu'on a battu aujourd'hui même
s'il ya quelques petites déceptions il
ya des rendements au global qui sont
quand même relativement correct en plus
du rendement la conjoncture économique
sur le marché du blé est plutôt
favorable par rapport aux 5 ans qui sont
écoulés ou là on a eu des gros gros
soucis à la fois de rendement de prix
etc
cette année on a des prix qui sont pas
des prix records mais qui se tiennent
quand même relativement bien et puis des
rendements qui sont dans la moyenne du
potentiel des pères donc globalement on
devrait arriver quand même à retaper un
petit peu les trésoreries des
exploitations qui ont été mises à mal
ces dernières années je pense après le
passage dans la moissonneuse batteuse
les grains de blé prennent la direction
des coopératives
l'analyse approfondie peut commencer des
mesures sur la quantité de protéines et
le taux d'humidité à l'onu il a l'air
plutôt pas mal peut-être un petit peu
deux grands verres comme laon pouvoir
mais dans l'ensemble les prières de bon
ça permet de nous donner une
identification sur le grain parce qu'il
était certain blé par exemple qui vont
partir pour faire des pâtes
du coup comment dire du pain et d'autres
qui vont partir pour l'animal sur ce
site de la coopérative ce cas elles
environ une cinquantaine d'agriculteurs
viennent déposer leurs récoltes
avec une capacité de stockage de 5000
tonnes on est au début de la récolte
mais les premiers rendements observés
sont bons donc on peut espérer une bonne
récolte des prix auront évolué
favorablement depuis un an et demi
donc à la faveur d'une grosse demande
asiatique
les pays d'asie soit la chine soit
l'asie du sud est près de 10 mille
tonnes sont collectés chaque année à la
coopérative de mai ray les récoltes sont
ensuite vendus à différents clients
meunier locaux entreprises de
l'agroalimentaire ou encore à
l'exportation